what's going on guys this is rob and we
are back with dark crisis again infinite
frontier as part of the dark crisis
event but what i want to do here because
this part really what i'm going to tell
you here in a second is going to be very
very important with regards to this
discussion and i know i have mentioned
this before but i do want to reiterate
this just because of the nature of what
we're going to be talking about here the
nature of of crisis on infinite earths
and then infinite crisis and final
crisis as we talked about before right
the original crisis event crisis on
infinite earth that basically got rid of
the multiverse that infinite crisis
brought it back and final crisis made
the heroes aware of it but here's an
important distinction to understand here
that when the multiverse returned during
the events of infinite crisis it was not
the multiverse the way it existed before
the events of crisis on infinite earth
now from a publishing perspective dc did
this because what it did is it allowed
them to bring back the characters from
the original multiverse but basically
modify their origins a little bit or
modify their characters a little bit or
something along those lines it wasn't
really dc saying like the multiverse is
back just like it was before crisis on
invented earth it was basically dc
saying the multiverse is back now let's
tell our stories and for years and years
and years this was not really a major
talking point among the characters
within dc comics with the exception of
the few psycho pirate is one of those
and this is an important thing here
because what he says is the multiverse
is real you and i both know that and yet
those words made people on earth zero
think i was nuts they locked me up threw
me in arkham for years instead of
listening to me helping me they hid the
truth my world was the original earth 2
the one before the first big crisis when
the multiverse was recreated my earth 2
no longer existed replaced by a brand
new fancy one how do you think that made
me feel now of course this is him
talking but this is one of the things
that i want to explain here right he
says now you don't know what happened to
me what happened to you do you your
world deemed no longer necessary a thing
of the past we've seen it happen again
and again right every time there is some
crisis someone gets hurt so much
heartbreak and horror it's tragic then
heroes of earth zero celebrate the win
but because of the restart they don't
even remember what they are missing and
you know it will happen and you have to
ask is my world next now darkseid
offered us a deal if you follow my very
simple instructions darkseid will
guarantee your world is protected away
from that dangerous earth zero but
someday i will call on you to back me up
and when i call you better come running
but hopefully everything goes according
to plan and it never comes to that right
now here's the importance of this
opening statement by psychopirate
because unless you're familiar with the
multiverse and really with a lot of what
happened in dc on the multiversal level
this whole thing is lost on you so again
reiterating here where infinite christ
has brought the multiverse back what
psychopirate is saying here is that the
version of earth 2 that came back after
the events of infinite crisis was not
the original earth 2 the way it was
depicted in flash of two worlds back in
19 was it 1961 or 63 or whatever it was
it's not that version of earth 2.
instead it was a modified and reworked
version of earth 2 for the modern era
psycho pirate is one of the only
characters in existence in all of dc
comics who not only came from an
alternate reality before the events of
crisis undefeated nurse but remembers
everything as it was before the events
of crisis universe he never forgot now
let's tie doomsday clock into this
because i imagine a lot of people are
kind of like okay so i thought doomsday
clock fixed all of that and it kind of
did and so the way that worked tried to
kind of tie all this together and gave
you guys this bit of a of a story in
terms of how things happen and what this
story is doing to change it is that if
the original crisis event killed the
multiverse infinite crisis brought it
back final crisis made the heroes aware
of it then the way flashpoint was
originally written it was barry allen
going back in time to save his mom's
life and in doing that he inadvertently
like totally reworked or restarted the
entirety of the earth zero universe
basically the main dc universe and so in
order to ensure things go back to the
way they were supposed to and the
original flashpoint event barry went
back and let his mom die when he came
back what dc did is they used that as a
way to basically consolidate all the
different storytelling brands they had
so wild storm and vertigo and all that
stuff into the main dc universe and that
gave us the new 52 relaunch in 2011.
doomsday clock came back and then
modified that yet again by basically
saying what had actually happened is
everything had effectively gone back the
way it was supposed to but what dr
manhattan did is he prevented uh jay
garrick from coming into existence and
with jay garrick basically no longer
existing or having been killed in the
train crash that in turn there was no
jsa and because there was no jsa the
justice league as it would traditionally
form didn't necessarily happen that way
that along with a few other things
basically led to manhattan removing
memories or an entire history from the
minds of dc superheroes the nature of
doomsday clock dr manhattan reversing
those actions as well as death metal
recreating the multiverse or
restructuring it basically saw those
memories returning back to the
superheroes but one of the things that i
want to specify here is that the
restoration of all those memories from
before the new 52 right the idea that
they remembered their whole histories
all they really remembered was
everything after the original crisis on
infinite earth event going forward into
like the new 52 and the relaunch and all
that stuff none of them remember
anything from before the original crisis
that's the important thing and that's
what's being said here is that that
original multiverse as it was existed or
at least as it existed and as it was
destroyed only psycho pirate remembers
so that's really an important
distinction to understand here having
said all that the way this does or at
least what this does is it picks up on
earth omega now remember earth omega is
a world that exists out there and i've
kind of waited up to this point to
basically rehash this if you guys recall
our coverage of infinite frontier number
zero which dc launched shortly after the
death metal event that what that did is
it told us that earth omega was a world
that darkseid was effectively imprisoned
on he was locked away by the octessants
he ultimately destroyed them and then
whatever happened happened this is
basically the follow-up to that and so
here on earth omega this is where
darkseid reigns it's where darkseid
rules basically everything but there's
also a much bigger force at play here
than what we're initially being shown
and so of course you have cameron chase
who wakes up here on this world and of
course ends up coming across bones now
of course this is basically bones
returning back to the villain that we
knew the old jsa alan scott villain and
so on and so forth so just kind of him
going back to the way things used to be
of course alan scott and his son
obsidian have also arrived here on the
scene to try to find their daughter jade
of course they're reunited with jade so
the family's kind of all here basically
wrapping up the plot thread of their
story over the course of this and one of
the things that's talked about here is
that because of the nature of earth
omega and because it is basically a
prison planet that can't simply just be
left on a whim the only ways to leave
this world are either by way of the
ships that were used to get here which
are basically destroyed or the
flashberry out now the flash of course
can do this by vibrating from one
universe to the next the problem is they
don't know of a flash that can do that
because barry allen's missing only for
them to realize that barry allen is
there but he's being used as a means to
power a gigantic device that exists out
there very similar to the way he was
used during the original crisis event
and so this is one of those wild things
because in the midst of all this
suddenly you have roy harper who shows
up here now we are going to get an
explanation of how it was that roy
harper came back it's going to be a
little haphazard and just sort of thrown
in there but it serves its purpose and
in all honesty we don't necessarily need
a great big huge full-on explanation
here instead what you end up getting is
cameron chase asking the question of
extract right again this person that
works for bones that's able to kind of
jump in and jump out at different places
literally extract people from locations
the cameron chase asked the question who
are you and why are you here right
you're like the thorn that's constantly
been here in everybody's side only for
for extract to remove her helmet and
reveal she's actually cameron chase the
original cameron chase from the original
earth 2 way back in the day before the
events of crisis undefended earth and so
it's it's kind of crazy that what you're
basically getting here is these various
individuals that that are appearing from
the original multiverse that existed
before the events of crisis on infinite
earth so i hope you're kind of picking
up what's going on here that what we
effectively have are two multiverses
going on because as you guys know in a
multiverse there's only one earth too
right there are worlds out there that
are similar to earth 2 but there's only
one world that's actually named earth 2
which means if this version of cameron
chase does not come from the modified
version of earth 2 post-crisis after the
events of infinite crisis then it means
she has to come from the original and
that's what she says the original
version of earth 2 but was erased during
the original crisis event which begs the
question how in the world have these
people returned if they come from a
multiverse that technically doesn't
exist anymore now again before anybody
actually gets any definitive questions
answered here what you end up getting is
a fight that basically breaks out
between the uh the injustice incarnate
that's basically led by a psycho pirate
so basically these different alternate
reality villains who exist out here and
the good guys is essentially all you
really get now one of the things to know
is that it's not simply just these bad
guys that are facing off against the
superheroes in fact it's earth omega
itself that this prison planet is as
much a kind of sentient place as
anything else because what you end up
having are like these sort of chains
that exist as part of this realm that
are actually keeping the heroes locked
in place now you do get a really really
cool moment where you actually end up
seeing calvin basically the the you know
president superman who essentially
breaks free of his change very similar
to like the old school superman cover
kind of a funny thing and to sidetrack
from the story for a second for those of
you guys who don't know the significance
behind that story uh one part of that
significance is actually a misconception
that was believed by fans at the time
and the second thing is the significance
of it from a publishing perspective so
the cover is actually superman issue
number 233 but when dc published it dc
referred to it on the cover as number
one best-selling comics magazine what
people thought this was is a number one
they thought it was a reworking like a
relaunch of the superman comics which of
course that was not necessarily the case
the other reason why this matters is
because this is when mort weisinger had
actually left superman and julia
schwartz had taken over this is the
infamous story where superman fought the
sand version of himself he ultimately
defeated him but then dc drastically
reduced his power so like he lost his
weakness to kryptonite but his powers
were also slashed in half different
things along those lines one of the most
reviled runs on superman in the history
of the character and so dc basically
backpedaled on that pretty fast and they
tried to return him to his to the the
version that people most loved the
problem is that by the time that
happened he died in the early 1990s and
his comics never recovered really until
rebirth to be honest with you guys the
point is that you kind of get this
bigger picture that sort of assembled
here the calvin has picked up on the
fact that it was machine head who was
part of the uh of the multiversal
justice league team that had actually
worked with lex luthor to perfect the
technology to be able to work and to to
navigate the multiverse and that's what
machine head says right he says you
wanted unity for all of us to work
together for the multiverse to be one
big happy family but psycho pirate is
right every time something bad happens
in the multiverse it happens because of
earth zero because of the main dc
universe is it because they are special
or because they are forever a ticking
time bomb literally every problem that
happens in the multiverse happens
because of them and he says you know
what it was that flash did he traveled
back in time to save his mother and when
he did he caused cracks in earth zero's
history creating a new reality and he
says did you know those cracks did not
stop on earth zero they splintered out
into the multiverse now one thing that
is obviously missing here is any
reference to doomsday clock and dr
manhattan and it's almost as if this
infinite frontier and dark crisis event
is essentially ignoring it right like it
didn't happen almost kind of undoing it
all or finding a way to basically
circumvent doomsday clock to almost make
it a sort of out of continuity story and
then craft a new story that essentially
fills the place that would otherwise be
left by doomsday clock to create a
cohesive series or i guess a long-form
crisis event because if we're being
honest with ourselves that's really what
this is right this is almost like uh
like an 11-year long crisis event it
started back in 2011 with uh with the
new 52 and it's just been running ever
since right like new 52 launched it was
a resounding success in the beginning
and then as time progressed and people
realized all that history belonging to
the characters was being wiped away fans
started to reject it dc corrected that
or at least tried to correct it with a
series of stories it didn't quite work
doomsday clock and dc rebirth fixed that
and then it's just been a series of
crisis events ever since so if we're
being honest ever since flashpoint we've
just been reading a gigantic crisis
story it wasn't necessarily published
that way it wasn't marketed that way and
i would even argue initially it wasn't
meant to be that way but it wasn't until
rebirth happened that it became that way
so again it's really kind of interesting
you know to see all this stuff sort of
tying together and coming together but
really like machine head reveals here
that he's the one that killed calvin's
lex luthor the one that we saw in the
last video that had basically been beat
to death right that lex luthor in that
reality got scared that he questioned
what it was that they were doing but he
still told machine head the weakness of
calvin which is meta knight right like
that version of kryptonite the
kryptonite from his own universe and he
says and this remnant of a dead reality
this thomas wayne from flashpoint i sent
form i wanted to torture that world but
it's gone so i'll simply take my revenge
out on him instead but it's one of those
things where they are all for various
reasons banding together for the purpose
of essentially either trying to destroy
earth zero or at the very least serving
dark side in such a capacity to where
the original multiverse seemingly can be
returned now that's one of the important
aspects of dark side himself that one of
the things to know is that with the
restoration of the multiverse all the
different iterations of dark side that
have ever been depicted or that have
ever appeared in dc comics have been
reconciled into a singular being in
terms of dark side as we know him now
and it's one of the reasons why a lot of
people are looking at this version of
darkseid and referring to him as true
form darkside now again one of the
things to point out trueform darkside is
not an actual incontinuity name for any
version of darkseid it really is just
something fans made up uh they made it
up in order to reconcile the various
depictions of darkseid but it's still
just completely and totally made up by
fans and until such a time that dc comes
along and refers to that version of
darkseid as true form darkseid that
version of darkseid does not actually
exist in the comics and it doesn't
matter what anybody tells you and so
following that you actually have this
really interesting thing where with all
the other heroes having been defeated it
really comes down to roy harper and
psycho pirate and what psycho pirate
reveals here is the whole reason why roy
harper's back is he says when the batman
who laughs transformed the world into
his own image during the whole death
metal event that batman from earth zero
the bruce wayne that we all know and
love that he used a black ring to
resurrect the dead which included roy
harper the big question to ask here is
why didn't roy harper die and the answer
given to him by psycho pirate is that
roy harper has a history of letting the
darkness inside of him that roy harper
knows pain and he knows isolation now
the reason why psycho pirate can
actually make this claim is that it's
much deeper than the idea of like roy
harper having died and things along
those lines what psycho pirates
referencing here because remember he
comes from the original multiverse he's
referencing the old neil adams and
dennis o'neill run of green lantern
green arrow right this story snowbirds
don't fly when uh when roy harper was
known as speedy and he was on drugs that
kind of a thing right he's like like
literally psychopath remembers all that
stuff so he's referencing those super
old school events that happened in the
life of roy harper that in a lot of ways
he'd just been made to forget it's why
you see drugs there it's why you see his
daughter there different things like
that it's referencing all that old
school stuff but what he says here is
that when the multiverse was recreated
just like how jordan's ring looked for
the fearless the ring that roy harper
has looked for someone who has suffered
and he says you can become its new
avatar just let yourself go now roy
harper responds and says that you say
this is some great weapon that i can use
this ring to save everyone here and this
is a really interesting caveat that's
given by psychopirate it's why it is
this guy is a lot smarter than he seems
he says yes you can but you know what
happens don't you right you turn into a
zombie that ring will take you over
it'll turn you into a mindless creature
of the dark it'll take away all your
pain and suffering and it will erase all
that you once knew i will offer you the
same deal i offered bones if you help me
now we will leave earth zero alone your
daughter will be safe and that's when
roy harper realizes his daughter is not
here on on earth omega that she's
actually back on earth zero but his
daughter is alive the hallucinations
that he thought he was experiencing by
way of the ring are not hallucinations
but tangible views right tangible
visions and so that's when he ultimately
makes the sacrifice and says okay like
if what this means is i have to
sacrifice everything i am in order to
save the life of my daughter and in
order to save my friends that's exactly
what i will do and why harper sacrifices
his life and in doing so basically like
spawns all these different you know
organisms and monsters and constructs
from this ring that he has and literally
they all just go and like free all these
individual superheroes that are out
there but in the process roy harper
starts to lose himself he basically
starts turning into a tried and true
black lantern and that's when
psychopirate says you really don't know
what it is that you've done here you
really have no clue what it is that
you've just unleashed and so were the
were the justice incarnate in like the
jsa and like all these groups start
banding together that when calvin shows
up and says you're done psycho pirate
there's a kind of disembodied voice that
comes out of nowhere and says it's too
late and any battle now will only feed
my power the multiversal barriers have
been created and all of its citizens
will kneel to me and with my omega
lantern at my side i control all that
this is the return of darkseid with that
being said guys we're gonna bring this
video to an end like i said infinite
frontier is amazing it's absolutely
great but we're gonna bring this to an
end thank you guys for watching and i
will catch you all later
peace
you